a reject nation how you doing it's got
sent to us SNL host Chadwick Boseman
Chadwick that's a one-minute you think
just a tease days hosting I does not
have any vibranium I got tell you guys
before we go into this there was one
night a few days ago I was watching like
Jordan Peele interviews which led to
watching interviews of Black Panther and
then I just started binging like oh
what's a Chadwick Boseman interviews and
I just kept going I love this guy I like
love this dude losing this one interview
very opened up about these two kids that
had cancer I saw that anyway I'm excited
I'm looking forward to the sketches he's
gonna do here yeah my you know he's
gotta be at least two funny would lease
Ripper SNL YouTube they put them up does
it go kind of decide like I guess these
were the best yeah
about what maybe if you had some what's
going on
Alice we're locked out of the studio to
open this door I don't have it guess the
show's canceled
[Laughter]
[Music]
I like that because I'm sure chadwick
boseman in real life is constantly
getting you know like I'm sure Robert
Danny's constantly being a pro you know
here sevens Captain America I get the
impression there's some shoes some
Marvel actors who are like I can't
shrink down in real life or grow huge
but I watched the Jimmy Fallon one where
he surprised fans chadwick boseman like
they would say something - like a poster
of chadwick and he would come out and
surprise them a lot of people would do
the Black Panther sign my king my king
people do that and it seems like he's
really genuinely touched by that and
just hearing all the interviews and
knowing what the movie has done for
African culture I think that when you
approach him that's like king or some
black man third reference or whatever
he's like yeah that's cool like just the
cultural shift where people like it's
people know what he sells it so
perfectly so much of this I think comes
together just on the charm of like how
natural he is in this little yeah I
don't think he's that mean like that
ever in real life no he's just such a
calm dude don't worry we can find a way
we can find a way to provoke him and
make him annoyed with our very presence
yeah there's very few celebrities who
are announced hosting where I'm like I
gotta check that out yeah and chadwick
boseman is one of those yeah I can't
wait to see the sketches he does a whole
episode yeah it's such like an intense
actor to do wondering uh will he be
funny sterling K Brown was hosted he did
a really good job actually okay yeah
that is like supernatural all the time
they had a Black Panther parody sketch I
didn't really I didn't find that funny
but there were other sketches that I
thought were pretty funny that he did so
yeah Chadwick Chadwick all right guys
who do you want to see a host SNL
obviously
Josh Brolin now I just yell at a room
yeah every sketch is gonna be like that
gonna be a whole lot of like Thanos you
know jokes sketches about like were
there in front of
green screen it's not gonna sketch like
a little sketch and asakari it'll be
enough for a full analysis would be
alright you can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell and
catch you on the flippety-flip and most
SNL reactions that we do we have that
just put on patreon because that's the
Nels pretty strict they usually get
blocked but yeah not YouTube friendly